Everything's so tiny.
(mysterious fast-paced music)
Today we're going to be taking
a surgeon try out test from Japan.
So I was actually was premed
when I was in college.
I did not continue being premed
because I wanted to make art.
I was premed up until my
junior year of college.
While I really enjoyed learning
about biology and science,
and I still really love science.
It just ultimately didn't seem
like the best choice for me.
(mysterious fast-paced music)
It's like a Jason Bourne movie.
Oh my gosh, that's a tiny ass bird.
This is stressful though,
I'm getting like sweaty
just watching this.
I feel like it seems like defusing a bomb.
That is insane.
They're doing it with one grain of rice?
It's sushi for ants.
Wait this is insane.
I don't know if I want to do this.
I don't know if I can do this.
(dramatic music)
Okay, this won't be so bad.
Wait, no, everything is
already going horribly wrong.
This is comical, I don't
know why I'm doing this.
I will say though,
that if I get more than two of these done,
I expect to automatically be
given a surgeon certification.
I just want to get my
face really close to it
and I feel like it'll make it
easier but it's not going to.
I'm so sorry in advance to my family,
my scholarship donors.
I failed you all.
Man, these creases are just so helpful.
You don't even realize
why you're making them.
Beautiful. Okay, so it is
more like a paper swan.
Look at this.
It's like the size,
what is this the size of?
It's like the size of my ear hole.
I'm reevaluating so many life choices.
I will not be making three of these
but I maybe I can make two.
Oh my god, I just realized
that I need to fold this again.
Are you serious?
I'm not sure if this really helps
because what if you're a
surgeon who just happens
to be really great at origami
but you suck at surgery.
Just do it.
Just fold the way that I want you to fold.
Is that what being a parent feels like?
You're just whispering
in your kid's ear like,
be a doctor.
I don't know if I buy this as a test.
Manual dexterity measure, sure.
Overall, surgery skill measure, mm.
Oh my gosh, let's go.
Wait no dang it, I'm missing a fold.
(dramatic music)
Look at those sitting next to each other.
I'm still okay with it
and I'm actually very happy with it.
I think I did great.
What do you think?
Am I getting that surgical
residency or what?
(dramatic music)
I'm very confident in this.
I think what I'm going to do
is I'm going to make an assembly line.
I'm going for the easiest
cut, if that makes sense.
Like I'm going for the section
where I can already see it shaped
or taking on the form of the larger model.
- [Sydnee] Would it be
funny if I accidentally
severed my finger with
this miniature knife?
So what's frustrating me a little bit
is that the texture of some
of these pieces of flesh
is more difficult to work with than others
but again, much like the human body.
- [Syndee] I'm sure when
they actually do it though
they probably have a specific
way they have to cut the fish
instead of just slicing a sad piece.
Best believe I will be eating everything
on this cutting board by the
time we are done here today.
- [Sydnee] Okay, we're going
to cheat this a little bit
and make it look nice from the top.
(laughing)
Moment of truth, this will
not be easy, my friends
but this is what I went to
fake sushi surgery school for.
I got a little bit cocky, you guys.
I just decided that I was
going to make it perfect.
(dramatic music)
Isn't a surgeon just making
sure that your patient is alive?
It doesn't have to be pretty.
I just want to take it home
and feed them to tiny
imaginary mouse friend.
I think I kinda crushed it.
I feel like I'm 2/3 of a surgeon now.
Definitely a lot better
than screwing around with
Lewis structures and the
Krebs cycle and stuff.
If I had to deal with the
stress of I could kill someone
literally every time I step into work,
that just doesn't sound very fun to me.
It makes me feel like for sure
I could not be a surgeon though.
Thank you to all the
surgeons and all the doctors
who go through an incredible
amount of commitment
to their education just
to help other people.
Thank you, that's awesome.
I think I won.
I'm proud of what I did here today.
This was so hard.
(upbeat music)